hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 4 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet I was really happy to see
that they finally did pink letter from
the books there were a few minor changes
to that and they had that really awesome
Daenerys unburnt end tag probably one of
the best soundtracks to that ever they
did take a few liberties with the idea
of Daenerys unburnt but I understand
totally what they were going for they
wanted to mirror that scene at the end
of season 1 when she hatched the Dragons
and everyone was just like oh my god
you're amazing we'll do whatever you say
so top 10 WTF and I'll explain book
changes as we go along the title of the
episode number 10 WTF book of the
stranger is all about the idea of death
in the unknown it's one of the aspects
of the 7 but you also have people who
seem like strangers like Theon when he
returns to Pyke Sansa seeming kind of
like a stranger almost when she appears
for Jon Snow probably one of the most
cry were at the moments of the episode
but one of the other functions that the
stranger serves in the faith of the
seven is leading people into the world
of death sort of the way the ferryman
leads people across the river Styx into
the afterlife in Greek mythology so like
Daenerys at the end of the episode is
going to lead people across the river
the giant river between the east and
Westeros into the new life that they
should be leading she had that big
speech about Khal Drogo's original
mission she's like we should be doing
that but you're not gonna do that I'm
gonna do that so number 9 WTF Stark
reunion just as Jon Snow is ready to
begin his new life doing god-knows-what
in the south taking a vacation getting
warm Sansa walks in and everybody just
starts crying you are not a human being
if you didn't cry a little bit during
that scene and it was so funny just
listening to them reminisce about yeah
like I used to be an [ __ ] you used to
be an [ __ ] how about these sulking in
the corner all the time but I love the
idea that retaking Winterfell is Santa's
idea we need to take our home back we
need to do it for our brothers and
sisters who might still be alive this is
one of the storylines that's gone wildly
off-book like they're way past Dance
with Dragons Jon Snow Sansa territory it
was kind of implied that they were
heading in this direction anyway but
they threw in a little hat tip to brands
flashback to the Tower of joy fathers
ghost will come back and murder me if I
don't take care of you so number eight
WTF Jon Snow wildling Sansa outnumbered
about two to one to the Bolton army
we're the others gonna come from when we
have other northern Lords that Sansa
think might be loyal to them still like
house mormon that we see in the trailer
and welcome back Littlefinger who tries
to inception Robin Arryn into helping
Sansa out so now we have the forces of
the Vale with the wildlings and
hopefully at least one or two other
northern houses so what might end up
happening is is Jon Snow and sonses
forces might still be a little bit
outnumbered but they're trying to
balance it out a little bit so it'll
wind up being a pretty even fight there
were a couple talks of armies sizes in
the episode like you have the Tyrells
with the second largest army in Westeros
so everyone's very concerned with
matching equal forces number seven WTF
the Tyrells versus the high Sparrow
so Cersei has this great plant they're
gonna make Margaery do a shame walk just
like she had to do at the end of season
five the reason the queen of thorns is
so adamantly against this is because
Margaery is the queen the queen can't be
seen doing something like this when
Cersei did it it was bad enough but she
technically was not the Queen anymore I
don't think it's so much about being a
prideful thing I think the queen of
thorns just recognizes that Margaery
needs to have the complete faith of the
citizens of King's Landing and if she
were to do the penance walk nobody would
respect her so she would have a zero
power it'd be impossible to control the
people of King's Landing after that
we've already seen this trailer seen
from later in the season so as we build
into the last couple of episodes armies
are marching towards each other I think
it's either episodes 8 or 9 is supposed
to be like the super long big battle
imagine an episode like season 4 episode
9 with the big battle at the wall
between the wildlings and the Nights
Watch imagine like a much bigger version
of that number 6 WTF though gravedigger
so when Marjorie's talking to the high
Sparrow he tells her his backstory I
walked out without even putting my shoes
on
that's a nice Easter Egg for the books
because in the books and they've done it
on the show too
the high Sparrow doesn't wear shoes like
he walks around with that one robe
that's the only rope he owns and he
doesn't have shoes so he just walks
around like that all the time but it's
nice to know that he was a cobbler like
he made shoes went to a frat party woke
up to the smell of molten hops and bong
resin threw up in his mouth and said
[ __ ] I'm out of here so if you've
ever been to a college party and passed
out then woken up the next morning and
had to smell the filth you would
probably do the same thing to
during that scene they say the word
graveyard twice which i think is the TV
show just trying to inception us and do
thinking about the gravedigger as in
gravedigger theory trial of the faith
cleganebowl so number five WCF going
back over into marine tyrion is like the
Abe Lincoln of slavers Bay there was
this Dan and Dave quote where they were
talking about Abe Lincoln in real life
if you don't know American history
Abraham Lincoln one of America's
greatest presidents was famous for
winning the Civil War abolishing slavery
but they said like in real life Lincoln
did the Tyrian thing where he tried to
bargain with the slavers first he didn't
want to make them go cold turkey on
slavery right away but a lot of the
people around him were just like Masson
dying grey worm and said this is
[ __ ] they'll never agree to your
terms this is only gonna end badly so we
all know what happened in America after
that the Civil War started
so betting dollars to donuts there will
be civil war in Mereen shortly number
four is ramsay killing osha may she rest
in peace
there was so much talk about filleted
men that I definitely feel like she's
one of the flayed people in the trailer
here so everybody pray for Rickon but it
was such a beautiful way to go out do
you eat them after no well then I've
seen worse
number three Theon his back end pike
he's back in Yara is the new queen of
the Iron Islands but we still have the
Kingsmoot the whole reason you're on
Greyjoy killed Balon Greyjoy was so that
he could take the sea stone chair so
while I'm not expecting civil war like
outright Civil War in the way that it's
happening in King's Landing a Marine
there's gonna be a Greyjoy battle royale
a la Kingsmoot shortly it seems like
based on the teaser footage for next
week's episode that's when we're gonna
see that no idea how long they're gonna
drag it out but Kingsmoot starts next
week number two we get to see a TV show
version of the pink letter and they
actually they read it out loud so you
definitely know they're going for the
book pink letter even though they
changed some of the words so in the
books there's a whole bunch of different
stuff happening that the plot is wildly
different the Nights Watch has not
mutiny against Jon Snow yet Sansa is
still safe in the Eyrie with
Littlefinger she's nowhere near Ramsay
in Ramsay has taken Winterfell so what's
happened is Melisandre has glamoured
like you know the way she Glamour's
herself with that gem around her neck
with her choker she Glamour's Mance
Rayder to
find out what's going on in rescue Arya
Stark who they say has been married to
Ramsay but it's really Jane Poole it's
called fake aria
so when people talk about the fake Aria
of the books they're talking about Jane
Poole that they kind of gave that plot
to Sansa they changed it wildly because
they didn't pretend that she wasn't a
stark they're like look he's marrying a
start on the TV show Mance Rayder is
already dead so that you know the plot
line has already changed wildly so a lot
of the text of the pink letter from the
books had to be changed to match that
but you get the idea Ramsay wants Sansa
back and he tells John I have your
brother I'm going to Flay him I'm gonna
do terrible things to your sister he's
just trying to do everything he can to
go John snow into a fight that he feels
like he is guaranteed to win because
they have what Sansa says is 5000 men so
in the way Tyrion says that the Masters
are going to underestimate Daenerys as
small Council that's what's going on
with Ramsay and Jon Snow Ramsay is
wildly overconfident he doesn't know
anything about what Littlefinger's
planning with the forces of the Vale and
he doesn't know about the other northern
Lord it might still be loyal to House
Stark
so really cool to see them do pink
letter and if anybody's charting you
know other changes at this point in the
books when the pink letter happens
Stannis is still alive - it was really
fun to see that moment with Brienne
where she's like I do not forgive and I
do not forget and I also say I'm now
shipping tour men with Brienne I do
believe one time he boasted having sex
with the bear Brienne has also had some
experience with bears number one WTF
moment of course is the sequel to
Daenerys unburnt Daenerys unburnt again
they really laid it on thick with some
of those Dothraki like they were like
you're definitely not one of the DOS
Colleen we are gonna do terrible things
to you
and she just shuts him down by burning
him alive it's an amazing moment but
they did take a few liberties with book
Daenerys so book Daenerys is unburnt
when she hatches the Dragons but the way
George R Martin explained it is because
blood magic is in play otherwise she is
capable of burning but what the TV show
is done is because you know like they
did with Jon Snow they want to make them
seem like really special characters
they're just presenting Daenerys as
completely 100% all the time
immune to fire I know everybody always
gets really excited when Emilia Clarke
gets naked for the show when Daenerys is
naked on screen but the bad news is
is this is a body double in the same way
that they used a body double for Cersei
Cheyne walk during season five so when
you're looking at naked Daenerys here
getting all excited you're not actually
looking at naked Daenerys I think that
emilia clark actually has a clause in
her contract now that says that she
doesn't have to be naked on screen so
anytime they do stuff like this they use
body doubles and they just digitally put
her head on that person's body so for
those of you that are asking because
every once in a while still get the
question is Daenerys immune to fire I
will say only on the TV show in the
books
she's only immune as long as there's
some magic in play let me know in the
comments though what was your favorite
moment from the episode there was a lot
of humor now Daario knows about jurors
grayscale at the rate of current
progression it seems like he'll totally
live to see season eight unless one of
the Dragons chooses head off
speaking of which I was totally
expecting the drogon would be what
helped Daenerys take control the
Dothraki not this big on Burt moment so
they are really speeding this along I
wasn't expecting this to happen till a
couple episodes later so you can kind of
see where they're headed with this
there's this big problem with the
Masters the combined forces of slavers
Bay
Daenerys needs to get rid of them
tyrians taking the diplomatic approach
but now that Daenerys has the allegiance
of the Dothraki she has this giant force
to fight them with so that's three big
battles that we know are happening we
have what looks like you're shaping up
in the east between the masters the
harpies in out Daenerys is forces with
these Dothraki we have King's Landing
and then we have the giant battle that's
shaping up in the north so the only
other thing that I'm super excited about
next week I mean I mean there's all
kinds of crazy stuff happening but we
finally see brand having a vision of the
night's king in his army too so not to
be forgotten we have a lot of like the
real world Civil War that's happening
all over the place we have the threat of
the supernatural war so what's gonna
happen is I'll do my Q&A next week just
like I would normally do there's a new
round of the giveaway it's a $20 Amazon
gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so my next game of Thrones
video will be that Q&A video while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here to learn all about our
plus l equals Jay the prophecy the
prince who is promised and you can click
here for my episode 3 video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight